it's one thing to count the number of
photos of leopards but how do you tell
the difference between one very
narcissistic leopard who likes to get
their photo taken and several incredibly
shy leopards the only data that you have
in order to tell the leopards apart is
their spots and their spot patterns many
kinds of patterned creatures across the
ecosystem their patterns are kind of
like human fingerprints and that they're
unique but slightly varied so it's a
very difficult task so that's really the
next step you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen
heusinger if someone asks you what snow
leopards and Vincent van Gogh have in
common you might think it was the
beginning of a joke it's not but if it
were Mark Hamilton a software engineer
and Microsoft cognitive services group
budding PhD student and frequent
Microsoft Research collaborator would
tell you the punchline is machine
learning
more specifically Microsoft machine
learning for Apache spark MML spark for
short a powerful yet elastic open-source
machine learning library that's finding
its way beyond business and into AI for
good applications such as the
environment and the arts today mark
talks about his love of mathematics and
his desire to solve big crazy core
knowledge size problems tells us all
about FML spark and how it's being used
by organizations like the Snow Leopard
Trust and the Metropolitan Museum of Art
and reveals how the persuasive advice of
a really smart big sister helped launch
an exciting career in AI research and
development that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Marc Hamilton welcome to the podcast
thank you thank you for having me I
always start my podcasts with
introductions and they're usually pretty
straightforward but you're differently
situated than most researchers I get in
the booth so I'm gonna start by letting
you tell me and our listeners who you
are what you do where you work and in
general what gets you up in the morning
yes I'm Marc Hamilton I'm a software
engineer on Microsoft cognitive services
team and I run an open-source machine
learning library called Microsoft
machine learning for Apache spark and
this library has kind of brought me into
the more Applied Research space so we do
a lot of AI for good type projects with
it and recently I've started my PhD over
at MIT
right now I'm part time and Microsoft I
used to be full-time I've been working
in Microsoft for the past three years
and during this next chapter of my life
I'll be part-time was getting a PhD in
computer science and mathematics as well
as working at Microsoft technically I'm
on Microsoft's applied AI team and so
Microsoft's applied AI team creates
things like the cognitive services so
translation text analytics computer
vision these types of projects and we
really heavily collaborate with
Microsoft Research so we collaborate
with John Lankford and the vocal rabbit
team we collaborate with like GBM and
the DMT k team and MSR Asia we also
collaborate with the AI for Earth team
and Lukas tropi his whole side of the
organization so we really have a lot of
different projects that kind of span
into Microsoft research where
personally I really like to work I
really like these kind of research
problems I like working on mathematics
and things that aren't necessarily easy
to implement right so since you're at
MIT you're physically situated in
Massachusetts are you working with
Microsoft there in Massachusetts as well
yeah I work at the Microsoft New England
research and development center of the
nerd will clearly put and MIT is right
next door so it makes it fairly easy to
kind of go back and forth between these
two although my team is actually
situated in Redmond so I come out here
about every month and visit Sudarshan
manager say hi you know make the rounds
and that's why I'm looking at your face
today instead of doing this move yeah
awesome well you've been working as a
software engineer and a developer but
you just started your PhD at MIT s
you've just told us want me to decide to
do that and what lines of research are
you most interested in right now it was
a tough decision because I couldn't
imagine working with a better team than
I do now and Microsoft but really what
it came down to is that I just missed
math I miss staring at a mathematics
textbook all day and really that kind of
intense learning is what I really missed
in my life and so that's kind of what
drove me back to the PhD but I didn't
really want to leave my team because
they're an amazing group of people and
amazing collaborators so I definitely
wanted to keep that connection alive as
I moved on to the PhD some of the things
I really want to start to tackle in my
PhD is really dive deep into the
mathematical foundations of deep
learning and how to use topics from more
advanced now to break mathematics to
really influence the kinds of
architectures that we can create to
learn and so some of these particular
threads that I'm interested in is
information theory because information
theory provides these really nice
mathematical tools to describe knowledge
here and crystallized way and what's
really exciting is you know now we have
the ability through things like
adversarial networks to really control
how information flows through deep
networks and that can really yield a lot
of interesting techniques and
applications one of the things that I'm
particularly interested in is using
information theory to help us understand
complex systems that we ordinarily would
have no idea where to start so things
like our own thoughts were the thoughts
of kind of the larger organism namely
the whole human race that kind of thing
would be really interesting to see if
algorithms could pull out structure and
really tell us what it is we're doing
when we're thinking or what mark
communicating
small aspirations there mark ya know I'm
always driven by the crazy core of
knowledge kinds of problems right like
I'm big we hear a lot about AI for good
these days which is sort of an umbrella
term for applying artificial
intelligence technologies to things we
feel good about as opposed to just how
can I get more clicks on my ads it
manifests itself in fields like medicine
agriculture the environment in the arts
so we'll talk about some of those
specific projects shortly but first
let's wait upstream and talk more
philosophically about using our power
for good and not for advertising what
are the promises of AI that excite you
most yeah I mean AI is very exciting to
me because it's one of the most powerful
tools that a developer has at their
disposal in order to create things of
unprecedented intelligence and ability
to do work in the real world I think
that it's important that organizations
like Microsoft and organizations across
the world really think about devoting
some of their resources to AI for good
type problems because it not only brings
a diversity of problems to the table it
also really can make a extraordinary
impact where it's not like you're just
optimizing the last three decimal places
out of an advertising click-through
scenario you're really fundamentally
changing the shape of a problem in its
solution in some way that may or may not
have had a lot of machine learning in
the past well and I want to stop there
for a second because usually the
problems to get the most attention are
the ones that potentially make the most
money or affect the bottom line of some
organization or person and some of these
problems under the AI for good umbrella
tend to be important things but things
that don't have a huge ROI at least at
the outset in people's minds and so it's
like why should we put our minds over
there when someone's going to pay us the
power of minds here so how's that
mapping out I mean you see Microsoft
putting its muscle and mind and money
behind AI for Earth so what do you think
about that yeah I think it's a lot like
research or like any other kind of
problem
where there's an incredible value to
diversity where if your entire business
model is parked in a single kind of task
or a single kind of automated solution
you one incredibly sensitive to shocks
in the market and two you never really
know where the next good idea is going
to come from a lot of times you get a
huge boost from diversity like when I
used to work in automated theorem
proving the hot topic when I worked
there was agent-based theorem provers
and they're kind of like lots of little
tiny algorithms that all try to prove
different parts of this theorem and when
you look at how long each one of these
little tiny algorithms takes to solve an
individual task it either solves it
instantly or it took years so we would
never solve it right and so that's when
people kind of started realizing we
needed a diverse collection of these and
we need to pool them together because
you know for some lines of research or
lines of thinking the problem can
immediately be solved whereas with other
lines of thinking and lines of work the
problem will never be solved quantum in
ten minutes maybe
[Music]
let's get more specific and talk
foundationally about a really cool
machine learning framework that you've
already alluded to and you gave it its
full name but it's called FML spark give
us an overview of FML spark and describe
some of the features that set it apart
yeah so what Microsoft machine learning
for Apache spark er ml spark for short
aims to do is really bring together a
lot of the different technologies that
currently exist in the Microsoft and
kind of more broader computational
ecosystem and put them all under the
same roof with a special set of
superpowers and these superpowers are
massively distributed so that you can
run it on hundreds to thousands of
machines at a time and elasticity so
what this means is that you can kind of
add in new computers as you see fit or
kill off some computers if they're
taking up extra resources and so this
kind of lets you make computations that
grow or shrink depending on how much
data is actually flowing through the
computation we want it to tackle the
largest scales that any industry could
possibly see but also be able to scale
down to a single node if you don't have
that kind of money lying around
more specifically what FML spark brings
to the table is deep learning in this
kind of large distributed Big Data
environment efficient gradient boosted
trees with light GBM we've recently
added Microsoft research work in vocal
rabbit on SPARC so ten of bringing that
into this distributed ecosystem talk
about vocal lab it for a minute every
time I say it I feel like Elmer Fudd but
I suppose that's the point yeah so vocal
wabbit is one of the newest additions to
ml spark and what vopo wabbit provides
is really hyper efficient text analytics
and now increasingly more it's
broadening into the scope of
reinforcement learning and multi-armed
contextual bandits so one thing that VW
colloquially put is incredibly useful
for is working with like text
classifiers text regressors and also
optimizing different text-based
situations so for instance MSN uses it
to optimize all of their ads
do what's called multi-world testing and
a lot of other companies are starting to
use it to kind of automatically update
and refine their content all right so
keep going a little bit more on the FML
spark value proposition if you have
different things that are kind of all
under the roof I mean one extra thing
that we've kind of lit up in the past
year is the ability for spark not just
to be a big data platform like a big
cluster computing framework but to serve
as what's called a micro Service
Orchestrator and so in software
engineering it's really useful to take
all of your different components and
encapsulate them behind nice little
packages little boxes that talk to each
other in the same way that me and you
talk to each other and this kind of
provides a nice separation of church and
state between different components of
your world it makes it easier for teams
to collaborate on them and things like
this and so what we do in ml spark is we
give the building blocks to create these
kinds of ecosystems of algorithms that
all talk to each other so that you can
kind of take your existing spark
computation and turn it into a web
service or you can take your big
collection of spark clusters and use it
to talk to a web service Wow and so it
kind of provides these two pieces as
well as doing integration with other
machine learning frameworks so all right
so what's the origin of it and who's
contributed because I'm hearing some
academic contributors some Microsoft
Research contributors and even Microsoft
proper mm-hmm it's a product yeah yeah I
mean um the product originally came out
of what's called Azure machine learning
and what we first started on was the
cognitive toolkit on spark or taking
deep learning and trying to parallelize
it across hundreds of computers at a
time and then the first project that we
ever worked on was the Snow Leopard
trust and that really provided the
impetus to grow the library and that
people saw its potential through working
on Snow Leopard recognition and gave us
a lot more time and it was a lot more
ideas a lot more challenges that we had
to kind of solve with the same library
and really forced it to grow in a lot of
different directions all right I want to
talk about that right now
the Snow Leopard trust
and there's a project under AI for earth
that you've done with the snow leopard
trust and this is sort of AI
technologies in conservation this is
about identifying counting and tracking
snow leopards which are very elusive
cats with motion trigger cameras or
camera traps why do we need to track
them in the first place and tell us why
mmm else Park makes a difference here a
few years back you might have heard the
news that snow leopards were considered
no longer did endangered whoo-hoo great
our leopards are no longer endangered
but there is a flip side to that and
that it's not like they discovered a
whole new leopard habitat or a whole new
swath of leopards they really went back
to some of their existing models and
they thought about it a little bit more
and they changed them a bit and a lot of
organizations the Snow Leopard trust
included I think that there really needs
to be a lot of thought before you take
an animal off the endangered species
list because that can be very
detrimental to the animals protected
status it suddenly means that a whole
bunch of rules that were designed to
actually preserve and protect the
leopard no longer apply and so what the
snow leopard trust really aims to do is
create a much more robust collection of
data to really hone in on the true
number of snow leopards that we can
accurately say what's going on with the
population of snow leopards and should
they or should they not be endangered
and you might think like what do I care
about this big cat in the mountains but
in order to protect the Snow Leopard
because it's the apex predator it's at
the top of the food chain you kind of
need to protect the entire food chain in
order to keep that formal going out
there so protecting the apex predator of
an ecosystem is incredibly important for
the ecosystems health as a whole if you
keep the apex predator alive some other
portions of the ecosystem start to swell
for instance when they brought the gray
wolf back into Yellowstone suddenly it
was a much larger place because all of
the herbivores that kind of secondary
trophic level were taken out by the
Wolves and so suddenly plants could grow
again and so you know the influence of
an apex predator can sometimes have like
profoundly interesting and beneficial
effects
food and the stability and biodiversity
right and also the snow leopard being a
stealthy cat you would have some need to
really understand how to count them
because are they not there or are they
just hiding yeah this is a particularly
tough challenge because in the snow
leopard trusts like multiple decades of
work on these creatures they've really
only been able to collar in the tens of
leopards and you can't really get much
data out of ten leopards and so the only
real option is to use camera traps and
camera traps are these automated systems
that and they have a camera and they
have an infrared detector that detects
motion and they'll fire a burst of
photos every single time something moves
in front of it and one of the problems
with this is that there's some snow
leopards but there's also a lot of
waving blades of grass and goats and
even locals that go and dance in front
of the camera there's a ton of fun stuff
in this data set so there's a lot to
call through so that's a good segue into
why MML spark what does the machine
learning add to the mix here it can be
incredibly difficult in order to
actually look at one of these photos and
rule out that a leopards not in the
photo because leopards are kind of
designed for this they're designed to
hide they're designed to be
indistinguishable from their
surroundings so for a human being this
can be fairly difficult and
time-consuming if you really want to be
sure that there's no leopards there and
so we've estimated that it would take
around 20,000 hours to cull through the
snow leopard trusts like 1.2 million
images that they have in their backlog
from all of these 50 to 60 cameras that
are out in various different locations
and so what we really need is a system
that can handle this incredibly large
upfront cost of processing 1.2 million
images but then elastically scale back
down to handle the kind of day-to-day
flow of data through the system how's it
going then have they said this new data
set confirms our suspicions that it's
not endangered or yeah so there's a few
extra steps that need to happen before
we can really get those concrete numbers
one of them which is the task
that we're working on now is that it's
one thing to count the number of photos
of leopards but how do you tell the
difference between one very narcissistic
leopard who likes to get their photo
taken and several incredibly shy
leopards the only data that you have in
order to tell the leopards apart is
their spots in their spot patterns many
kinds of pattern creatures across the
ecosystem their patterns are kind of
like human fingerprints and that they're
unique but slightly varied so it's a
very difficult task so that's really the
next step and what we've already
provided is kind of a great burden
lifted off the snow leopard trust
shoulders but this next burden of
matching them up they still have to do
it kind of CSI style where they print
out all the photos and they plaster them
all over whiteboards and try to piece
this puzzle together manually in a
conference room as opposed to something
that is more efficient and automated and
scalable okay so that's interesting
because I was thinking that's exactly
where the machine is going to do better
than I would do at telling the
difference between the narcissist and
the introvert and that said then we're
still back to human labeling and data
identification yeah yeah so you know
there's a lot of nice technologies out
here now that really aim to solve this
problem in a generic way the one that
we're looking at is called hot spot er a
lot of researchers in the literature
have kind of come up with automated ways
in order to do species identification
based on patterns and a lot of these
algorithms they really require you to
understand not just is there a leopard
in the photo but where is the leopard in
the photo so some of the work that we've
done to try to address this is that we
have this classifier this thing that can
say yes there's a leopard and no there's
not a leopard but it would be ridiculous
to think that this classifier didn't
actually know where the leopard was and
yet performed well and so we can
actually pull this information out of
the classifier by asking it a series of
questions and this method is called Lyme
or locally interpretable model agnostic
explanations that can take any sort of
classifier and look into its brain so to
speak and figure out what is actually
causing the clasp
to occur and when you do this with the
leopard classifier you find that it kind
of hones in on the leopards body and we
hope to then pipe this into hot spot err
and really use that to complete the
end-to-end pipeline in a way that
doesn't really require any human effort
or any human labeling
[Music]
well another area that falls under the
AI for good umbrella is a fairly recent
trend to deploy AI in cultural
preservation and engagement and these
are two sides of an important coin so
you've got a great story about how
Microsoft MIT and the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in New York City got
together to create what you call gen
studio and employ Ganz or generative
adversarial networks in the world of
fine art yeah so this collaboration came
out of an initiative that the
Metropolitan Museum of Art started where
they took their entire collection and
they took really high-quality photos of
everything and a lot of different angles
put it together with all of the metadata
about the artists and put these as open
access online so that anyone from across
the world developers anyone looking to
enjoy and use this art in their projects
could really grab it without needing to
worry about the rights needing to worry
about licensing and so seriously I can
go and use any piece in the Met
collection in anything I want to do yeah
they've done this for about 400,000
different pieces in the Mets collection
maybe they are there might be like a few
million I suppose but can't quote me on
those times yeah so they released this
large open access catalog and then they
employed a team to go through the
collection and tag the art with what's
actually being shown in the air and so
people and flowers and dogs and cats and
turkeys and what-have-you and so not
only do you have the actual images you
have some semantic knowledge about
what's going on inside and the semantic
knowledge is slightly different than
what you'd get from a normal classifier
because it's not that it's tagging a
physical turkey it might be tagging the
engraved metal in the shape of a turkey
so things that wouldn't normally be
picked up by algorithms so it's a very
useful data set and what they really
wanted to do was create an environment
where people could use all this data to
create interesting applications or
create applications to reach a broader
segment of people and that's really
where we came in is that we took this
data and we
wanted to create an experience that got
people excited about not just the
Metropolitan Museum of Art's collection
but the way that we and algorithms kind
of think and make art and a real
platonic and philosophical sense keep
going I mean I love all aspects of this
project especially the idea of
generative adversarial art can you
unpack that a little bit cuz wow yeah so
what a generative adversarial Network
tries to do so tries to model different
distributions it tries to kind of mimic
the collection of data that you have
available in the collection of data that
we had available was the Metropolitan
museum's collection and so the
particular algorithm that we used
learned kind of like a human being does
in that it starts out by creating images
about the size of a postage stamp you
know 8 by 8 pixels and slowly but surely
as it learns it grows the image and what
this allows you to do is generate very
high-resolution photos of art and what
we really aim to do primarily is to
create an application that lets you
explore with this generative adversarial
network and then find related pieces to
your creations in the actual collection
so not only do we have a gam we have an
ability to take created works and
reference them via a custom reverse
image search and pull them up in the
Mets actual search collection and then
find these kinds of connections and give
people a starting point to branch out
and explore this kind of 400000 work
database that they have assembled
definitely one of our goals and as we
continue on in this vein of work is to
create things that would get school kids
excited get people who wouldn't
ordinarily go to the museum get people
who have never been in the same 100
square mile radius is the museum to
start to play with these because it's a
hosted online anyone can go to the
website and start to explore what is the
website so we know those gen dots to do
that's it that's it that's GE n dot
studio yeah ok I'm going there next I'm
really interested in some common themes
I'm detecting here we're using AI
to preserve conserve and save but also
to create generate and innovate let's
head back to the more philosophical for
a minute and talk about creativity and
machines in general I know you have big
ideas why don't you share some of your
thoughts and then tell us what the world
looks like if you're wildly successful
right now I think that AI creativity is
a bit limited and that it really mimics
what humans have created and there are
ways to think about taking this outside
of the box you know you can think about
encoding the temporal evolution of art
and seeing if an algorithm could
extrapolate into the future but it
doesn't really to me feel like it
addresses that problem and I mean the
closest thing that I've found to
something that I hope exists or that we
can discover is that a few years back
there's a lot of hype about algorithms
that created their own languages and in
some sense what this research kind of
showed is that a language is not
something that is learned or taught it
really emerges out of the physical world
in that a language is needed in order to
communicate and solve problems in the
world and can emerge by itself in a
multi-agent system and so one of the
things that I think would be a nice holy
girl is if we can create a kind of
multi-agent system that rediscovers art
or where art emerges is a real pivotal
fundamental concept you know it seems
like art and language are intimately
connected and that visual arts at least
they convey ideas they beam ideas across
from the wall into your brain in the
same way that I'm beaming ideas to you
and vice versa
through our speech and so the hope is
that these can kind of be modeled in
similar ways and they have similar
structures it will be interesting to see
you know if there is a way to kind of
create art without just mimicking human
beings like does it require multiple
agents does it require just one my guess
is that it would require multiple and
that this is kind of how language has to
arise and I would assume that it's just
as complicated as language at the very
least well that's a good segue into the
next question I can't let any podcast go
by without ass
what could possibly go wrong and I
always ask what keeps you up at night
when we start talking about generating
art from art that already exists is
there going to be any problems with
copyright or plagiarism or even is it
valuable if a machine made it in the
same way it's valuable if a person made
it yeah and I think those are really
good questions that we need to tackle in
that you know you don't want the things
that you use to study the beauty of
human creativity to cheapen the beauty
of creativity personally I feel that art
isn't just defined by the pixels and
that art has a long creation story and
makes you think and makes you think
about the creator and how it was created
which i think is something that these
algorithms will really never have in
quite the same way as a human being does
there are problems in generating art
like cheapening the human experience and
also plagiarism but I think that also
what's probably more problematic is
adversarial networks when they're
employed by really bad actors there's
been a huge amount of controversy around
like deep fakes and these kinds of
really just sinister applications of
adversarial networks and it's very
difficult to square this with pursuing
research in machine learning because it
seems like you know once you create
something that you can't put the genie
back in the bottle all right you know
humanities and the Social Sciences have
the institutional review board I mean I
don't see why a I shouldn't have a
similar thing where people kind of think
about what they're doing before they
make it you know it might make growth a
little bit slower but it makes a little
bit Stabler and I might rather have a
little bit slower Stabler growth than
very very volatile potentially fast
paced growth
[Music]
all right it's story time mark you're
only 25 so your story's not a long one
yet but I think you already have a few
plot twists tell us your background and
how you ended up working where you're
working and going where you're going
yeah so my research life has definitely
taken a lot of twists and turns in that
when I originally started research I was
working in a photonics lab and then I
went to particle physics at the LHC and
then astronomy and then metamathematics
kind of trying to chase the foundation
of life and then finally to machine
learning but I think that along the way
you pick up a lot of different exciting
viewpoints you hear about random other
whole branches of thought and you also
get to interact with really powerful
mentors and that I think that what's
helped me throughout my life is the help
of people like my sister and my teachers
and my current manager who really helped
form your research directions your
opinions and how you want to conduct
your research and work with people and
collaborate come back to your sister
because it's the first time anyone cited
their sister as a you know it's there's
a really big inspiration for me I think
that you know my sister from the very
GetGo in high school was like no mark
you're taking science research I don't
care how nerdy you think it is and okay
how many friends you're gonna lose yeah
my sister she's eight years older than
me she's just opened her lab in Arizona
State University is studying
Legionnaires disease all right what's
her name so is Kerry Hamilton she's
actually a MSR just uh we had a joint
project where we looked at figuring out
ways to measure Legionnaires
Legionnaires is a certain waterborne
pathogen and figure out how we can take
the Legionnaires data and construct
limits so that the government can say
hey we don't want to see any more than
this amount of Legionnaires bacteria
flowing out of your tap if you want
people to be safe it's
are there other Hamilton's we ought to
know about those are the two that are in
their research sphere me those are the
ones we want to know about
all right well where'd you go to school
yeah so I went to Yale in New Haven and
studied math and physics there so
started out my work there at the Large
Hadron Collider and kind of looking for
certain alternatives to supersymmetry
namely the vector like quark one of the
the most influential advisors in my life
was Meg early and she worked in active
galactic nuclei and what we aim to do
there was to look at kind of the
farthest black holes namely these things
called active galactic nuclei and figure
out their distance from a very small
number of measurements and then from
there I kind of moved into more abstract
mathematics that took me into Germany
into this groups that created a system
of meta mathematics so it's math that
creates math and the goal is to kind of
create things like theorem provers up in
this very abstract meta mathematical
space and then apply them to all the
languages that come out of this meta
mathematical language and so that was a
fun little foray into an intense realm
of mathematics where in Germany is this
madman jakob x' university in bremen
germany all right so then you came back
here obviously yeah and landed at
Microsoft yeah yeah came to Microsoft
and it was really fortunate to land in
Sudarshan or at KU Nathan's group and
that he also has like a deep love for
mathematics and linear algebra and
things and really has been my guides
through Microsoft ever since and kind of
followed him very closely as he's really
was one of the foundational people who
built Microsoft machine learning for
Apache spark and continues to support it
and support all of its related efforts
well my new favorite question is what's
one interesting thing about you that
people might not know and how has it
influenced your career path I guess
there's a few things that I do outside
of just thinking about math and one of
the things that I've really come to love
is cooking these days you know I think
that cooking is one of the best ways to
take your
hard elbow grease and turn it into
something that's incredibly satisfying
without having to wait very long you
know it's not like coding where you put
in a lot of hours and then you change
the color of pixels you actually do
enjoy the things that you create as we
close since you're on the kind of front
end of your life in research if that's
where you land
I'm curious about your vision for the
future horizon in AI what parting
thoughts would you leave with our
listeners in terms of maybe what you're
most looking forward to as you move
ahead in the field yeah I think that one
of the things I'm most looking forward
to is just getting a large diversity of
ideas and you know meeting more of the
research community and seeing what kind
of things are keeping them up at night
and seeing kind of how they relate I'm
excited to start to uncover more of the
beautiful structure underlying
intelligence and I think that it's
surprising and it's complex and also one
of the things that I hope to do in the
PhD is really explore how the math
established in the pure math community
and abstract algebra and things like
this can help influence some of the work
we're doing in machine learning in that
it kind of feels like we are really
doing a lot of algebra these days and
machine learning and that we're thinking
about the structures of different things
and how these structures relate and so
I'd love to understand a little bit more
about how these different kinds of
mathematical tools can create systems
capable of understanding the world to a
much better and more interpretable
degree real quick before we go do you
have any experience having gone to the
areas where snow leopards live or is
this just all abstract for you yeah I
mean one thing that was really exciting
was that we actually got to go to
Kyrgyzstan and meet up with the snow
leopard trust and take a Honda CRV deep
into the mountains where we got several
flat tires and actually like see some of
these camera traps and that we went to
what's called the sharm sheet river
valley and it was really nice in that it
kind of made this dataset feel a lot
more real and that were actually able to
like see one of the cameras and also
just see
how remote and difficult it is to
actually get out there yeah and what was
particularly exciting about this valley
is that recently when we had first
started doing this work they only had
one camera there and they found a Snow
Leopard it was kind of the first
documented evidence of finding a leopard
in this particular valley and so now
they really want to scale out their
efforts to actually understand is this a
single leopard passing through because
they have incredibly large range or is
this indicative of a more established
leopard population that needs to be
properly preserved right so they're
really starting to build out an
infrastructure around this River Valley
and it was really exciting to see them
do this yeah actually getting to meet
Coast Dube kind of the head of the Snow
Leopard Trust to there and getting to
meet his whole team in that we're just
not the only people doing really
exciting things around Snow Leopard
technology they have collaborations in
Asia creating 3d Snow Leopard camera
traps and all sorts of really exciting
things they've now invested in a series
of drones they can do thermal imaging
and kind of sweep through the entire
ecosystem and get understanding of
biomass and things like this well I'm
thrilled that you were able to join us
in person so I didn't have to use a
camera craft service Marc Hamilton
thanks for joining us on the podcast
today so much
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about how researchers are
using machine learning for social good
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]